From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台，节目是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Yes, we need the police to come out to Prairieland Detention Center. I don't know what's going on outside. They just told me to call.
是的，我们需要警察到 Prairieland 拘留中心来。我不知道外面发生了什么。他们只是让我报警。
OK. You don't know what's going on?
好的。你不知道外面发生了什么吗？
No, sir. I think they doing fireworks.
不知道，长官。我想他们在放烟花。
This is a 911 call on the Fourth of July a year ago, around 11:00 PM, Alvarado, Texas, about an hour outside of Dallas.
这是一年前“七月四日”独立日那天晚上 11 点左右的报警电话，地点在德克萨斯州阿尔瓦拉多，距离达拉斯大约一小时车程。
Yes, sir.
好的，长官。
The woman calling works at the Prairieland Detention Center. She at the front desk there. And she's calling because a bunch of people have suddenly shown up outside wearing black, some in masks, lined up on the other side of this long, barbed wire fence. They're setting off fireworks. It's really loud. This facility is a detention center for ICE, full of people being held on immigration charges. Somebody in the crowd outside has a megaphone, starts calling out to the detainees inside. "Esperanza! Hope! You are not forgotten." More fireworks go up.
打电话的女子在 Prairieland 拘留中心工作，她在前台。她报警是因为一群人突然出现在外面，身穿黑衣，有人戴着面具，排队站在长长的铁丝网围栏对面。他们正在放烟花。声音非常大。这个设施是移民及海关执法局（ICE）的拘留中心，关押着因移民指控被扣留的人。外面人群中有人拿着扩音器，开始向里面的被拘留者喊话。“埃斯佩兰萨！希望！你们没有被遗忘。”更多烟花升空。
Oh, somebody's trying to get in. Can you hurry up and send somebody?
噢，有人试图闯进来。你们能快点派人来吗？
Yes, ma'am. Someone's trying to get in?
好的，女士。有人试图闯进来？
They outside walking the perimeter. I don't know, sir.
他们在外面绕着围栏走。我不知道，长官。
All right. We got them en route, OK? Call us back if anything changes.
好的。我们已经派人赶过去了，明白吗？如果情况有变，再给我们打电话。
OK, bye-bye.
好的，再见。
Bye.
再见。
A police officer rushes out to the facility, Lieutenant Thomas Gross from the Alvarado PD. As soon as he switches on his siren, the dash cam activates in his car and his body cam turns on. He turns into the Prairieland parking lot. In the car headlights, you can see somebody has sprayed "Fuck ICE" on a guard shack. Then as he pulls up, he sees somebody running in front of his car.
一名警察赶往现场，他是阿尔瓦拉多警局的托马斯·格罗斯中尉。他一打开警笛，车上的行车记录仪就激活了，随身摄像头也开启了。他拐进了 Prairieland 的停车场。在车头灯下，你可以看到有人在警卫室上喷了“去你的 ICE”。然后当他停下车时，他看到有人在他车前奔跑。
Hey, stop!
嘿，站住！
He jumps out of the car, drawing his gun in one hand, walkie-talkie in the other. And this next thing happens almost immediately, just six seconds after he gets out of the car.
他跳下车，一只手掏枪，另一只手拿着对讲机。接下来的事情几乎是立刻发生的，就在他下车六秒后。
[GUNFIRE]
[枪声]
Fuck! Fuck! Fuck, I'm hit!
该死！该死！该死，我中弹了！
"I'm hit," he yells. He's shot in the upper shoulder, by his neck. He fires back three times.
“我中弹了，”他喊道。他的上肩部、靠近脖子的地方中弹。他回击了三枪。
[GUNFIRE]
[枪声]
Shooter runs off and hides in a field-- sunflower field, actually. They're all around the detention center. Then cops of all sorts arrive-- local police, Sheriff's Office, Texas Rangers. And they start arresting people. Some are on the streets, walking nonchalantly away as if they just happened to be here, they are not involved. They have backpacks which the cops try to search.
枪手逃跑并躲进了一片田地——其实是向日葵田。拘留中心周围全是这种田。随后各路警察赶到——当地警察、警长办公室、德州游骑兵。他们开始抓人。有些人走在街上，漫不经心地走开，好像只是碰巧路过，与他们无关。他们背着背包，警察试图搜查这些背包。
(SUBJECT) POLICE OFFICER 1: Take off the goddamn backpack. If you move, you will be shot. Do you understand me? I am taking off your backpack.
（对象）警察 1：把该死的背包脱下来。如果你敢动，就直接击毙。听懂了吗？我来帮你脱背包。
Everybody's on edge because an officer has been shot. The police officer, it turned out he was not badly hurt. The bullet entered his shoulder, came out his back just below his neck. He was released from the hospital later that night. The guy who shot the cop and disappeared into the sunflower field, he hid there for a whole day. Eventually, some friends snuck him out. They were all caught.
大家都非常紧张，因为有一名警官被击中了。事实证明，那名警察伤得并不重。子弹从肩膀射入，从脖子下方后背穿出。他当天晚些时候就出院了。那个枪击警察并消失在向日葵田里的家伙，在那里躲了一整天。最终，几个朋友把他偷运了出来。他们全都被抓住了。
What happened that night on the Fourth of July, one year ago, it all ended up in court. It became this major trial, where two very different stories were told. The defendants say this was a protest gone wrong. Nobody was supposed to get shot. In other words, this was like tons of other anti-ICE protests that had been happening all over the country, outside its facilities, where people gather and make noise to communicate with detainees. But the FBI director, Kash Patel, had a different view. Here he is talking to Fox News host Larry Kudlow.
一年前那个“七月四日”晚上发生的事情，最终闹上了法庭。这成了一场重大审判，双方讲述了两个截然不同的故事。被告方称这只是一场失控的抗议活动。没人打算开枪。换句话说，这就像全国各地其他针对 ICE 的抗议一样，人们聚集在设施外，制造噪音与里面的被拘留者交流。但联邦调查局局长卡什·帕特尔有不同的看法。他正在接受福克斯新闻主持人拉里·库德洛的采访。
This was a coordinated, planned attack by dozens of individuals to murder police officers. And Larry, a police officer was actually shot in the neck. These guys came and staged a scene at a detention center using fireworks, then brought in long guns and rifles. They were kitted out in bulletproof vests and masks and opened fire at law enforcement.
这是一场由数十人精心策划、有组织地谋杀警察的袭击。拉里，一名警察确实被击中了脖子。这些人带着烟花在拘留中心闹事，随后带来了长枪和步枪。他们穿着防弹背心，戴着面具，向执法人员开火。
Patel was confident who was behind this.
帕特尔非常确信幕后黑手是谁。
This is breaking news, Larry. Just hours ago, a grand jury indicted two members of an Antifa-affiliated cell. 20 individuals have been charged so far. But the key here is, for the first time, we have charged these two individuals with material support to terrorism for their involvement in Antifa. And yes, Antifa exists. It's a terrorist organization.
这是突发新闻，拉里。就在几个小时前，大陪审团起诉了两名隶属于“反法西斯运动”（Antifa）组织的人员。目前已有 20 人被起诉。但关键在于，我们首次指控这两名个人因参与 Antifa 而提供恐怖主义物质支持。是的，Antifa 是存在的。它是一个恐怖组织。
To Larry Kudlow, the Fox host interviewing him, that made a lot of sense.
对于采访他的福克斯主持人拉里·库德洛来说，这很有道理。
So let's just-- one more moment on that. People on the left and the far left say that Antifa doesn't exist. It's a state of mind, blah, blah, blah, blah. I mean, if they're not real, then how come two people were indicted? They have to be real. It's not a state of mind.
那我们再多说一点。左派和极左派人士说 Antifa 不存在。那只是一种心态，巴拉巴拉什么的。我的意思是，如果他们不是真的，那怎么会有两个人被起诉？他们一定是真的。那不是一种心态。
Soon, 13 more people were charged with material support to terrorists.
不久之后，又有 13 人被指控向恐怖分子提供物质支持。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
The indictment in this case saying this was the work of a North Texas Antifa cell, this came out a month after Charlie Kirk's assassination. You may remember, in that shooting, a bullet casing was etched with the words, "Hey, fascist, catch."
本案起诉书称，这是德州北部一个 Antifa 组织的杰作，起诉书是在查理·柯克遇刺案一个月后发布的。你可能还记得，在那次枪击事件中，一枚弹壳上刻着“嘿，法西斯，接招吧”。
And a big part of the administration's response back then was to target Antifa as a domestic terror group in a national security memo, setting policy for the entire federal government. This Texas case with these defendants was a chance for the administration to lay out their best argument that Antifa is, in fact, a terror group operating here and now in the United States.
当时政府应对措施的一大部分，就是在国家安全备忘录中将 Antifa 标记为国内恐怖组织，并为整个联邦政府设定政策。这起德州的案件对于政府来说，是一个展示其论点的机会，即 Antifa 实际上就是一个此时此刻在美国运作的恐怖组织。
And OK, just stepping back for a second. Right now in America, whether you believe or not that Antifa even exists is tied to a whole other set of beliefs. And just to generalize here for a second, blue America says Antifa does not exist as an actual, functioning organization. Lots of reporting backs this up. And going into this trial, the administration has not been able to point to any leaders or infrastructure or any of the normal things that a terror group has.
好的，我们先退后一步。现在在美国，无论你是否相信 Antifa 的存在，这都与另一整套信仰挂钩。简单概括一下，蓝色美国（民主党支持区）称 Antifa 作为一个实际运作的组织并不存在。大量报道支持这一点。在进入审判时，政府无法指出任何领导人、基础设施或恐怖组织通常具有的任何特征。
Meanwhile, red America and right-wing media say, of course, Antifa exists. Just look at all these activists around the country dressed in black, vandalizing stuff, wreaking havoc. How could that not be a thing? This trial in Texas, this was going to be the place where we were going to finally fight this one out, in public, and figure out, is Antifa real? So how did the government make the case? Was it convincing?
与此同时，红色美国（共和党支持区）和右翼媒体表示，Antifa 当然存在。看看全国各地穿着黑衣、大肆破坏、制造混乱的抗议者就知道了。怎么可能不存在呢？这场在德州的审判，本来将是我们要公开辩论并弄清楚“Antifa 是否真实存在”的场所。那么政府是如何举证的？有说服力吗？
The trial was not recorded, but that did not stop our producer, Zoe Chace, who's never one to shy away from a fool's errand. She was there for three weeks in the courtroom, writing down everything that happened in notebooks as the government tried to prove its case beyond a reasonable doubt.
庭审没有录像，但这并没有阻止我们的制片人佐伊·蔡斯，她从来不怕做吃力不讨好的事。她在法庭上待了三周，把发生的一切都记在笔记本上，看着政府努力在排除合理怀疑的情况下证明其指控。
Also, she got to know one of these supposed terrorists. It was a hard-to-describe mix of being a longtime church lady married to a guy who loved Dungeons and Dragons. Her nom de guerre was Candied Dynamite. We heard the arguments, we heard the counterarguments, we heard the verdicts, all this hour. Stay with us.
此外，她还了解了其中一名所谓的恐怖分子。很难描述她，她是一个长期的教会女士，嫁给了一个热爱《龙与地下城》游戏的男人。她的化名叫“糖果炸药”。我们在这一小时里会听到辩方论点、反方论点以及判决结果。请继续收听。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
This American Life, Act One, The Trial.
《美国生活》，第一幕：审判。
OK, so from the start, this trial was pretty unusual. For starters, they had a hard time convening a jury. Lots of potential jurors either had strong opinions about ICE, or about protesters, or about Antifa. And on day one, the judge, who's a bit of an intense character, called a mistrial because of a shirt that one of the defense attorneys was wearing.
好了，从一开始，这场审判就非常不同寻常。首先，他们很难选出陪审团。许多潜在陪审员要么对 ICE 有强烈看法，要么对抗议者有强烈看法，要么对 Antifa 有强烈看法。在第一天，这位个性强硬的法官因为一名辩护律师穿的一件衬衫而宣布审判无效。
So they had to start the entire thing over, this time without giving attorneys a chance to question potential jurors. We did a little story about this on our show a couple months ago. And the judge also decided to move the trial upstairs into his courtroom, the courtroom he's accustomed to, a much smaller room. I'll let Zoe take things from here. Here's Zoe Chace.
所以他们不得不重新开始整个过程，这次没给律师盘问潜在陪审员的机会。几个月前我们在节目里讲过这个小故事。法官还决定将审判移到楼上他自己的法庭，那个他习惯的、小得多的房间。接下来的内容交由佐伊来讲述。这是佐伊·蔡斯。
The courtroom was packed-- nine defendants, each with, like, two lawyers-- so a lot of lawyers-- plus the prosecution, plus everyone else, reporters and family members and law students and interested observers, all jostling, a little fighting. The court sketch artist sat basically on my right knee on the first day with this huge easel spread out in front of us like a sail.
法庭挤满了人——九名被告，每人大概有两个律师——所以律师非常多——加上检方，加上其他所有人，记者、家属、法学生和感兴趣的观察者，大家都在推搡，有点混乱。庭审素描艺术家第一天基本上就坐在我的右膝上，巨大的画架像帆一样在我们面前展开。
Judge Pittman likes to open trial days with little homilies. He says, I urge you all to remember the saying from General Patton-- this will be our watchword for the trial. "You cannot be disciplined in the great things and undisciplined in the small things." The judge wants things done a certain way. "Once you find your seat," he says, "stay in it."
皮特曼法官喜欢用简短的训诫来开启每一天的审判。他说，我恳请大家记住巴顿将军说的一句话——这将是我们审判的座右铭。“在大事上不能守纪律的人，在小事上也不会守纪律。”法官希望事情按照特定的方式处理。“一旦你坐下，”他说，“就不要乱动。”
So we begin. The prosecutors make their opening statement saying this was an Antifa attack. They are career government prosecutors in the Northern District of Texas. They are matter-of-fact and colorless. And then the defense gets to make their opening arguments, and they're all showmen to one degree or another. They make their case over and over, because nine defendants. This was just a protest, they said, that went off the rails.
于是我们开始了。检察官在开庭陈词中说这是一场 Antifa 的袭击。他们是德州北部地区的职业政府检察官。他们讲起话来实事求是，枯燥乏味。然后辩方进行开庭陈词，他们多多少少都有点表演天赋。他们一遍又一遍地陈述观点，因为有九名被告。他们说，这只是一场失控的抗议。
The prosecution starts rolling out its evidence the next day, in pretty dramatic fashion. They wheel in a cart full of boxes, like an Amazon delivery. The boxes were tall and skinny. Looked like someone had ordered a bunch of curtains. I didn't know what was in them. They bring in a parade of law enforcement to walk through everything they found that night, each item entered into evidence. The officers walk through body camera footage and dash camera footage of the defendants being arrested and searched, and the cops finding a lot on them.
检方第二天开始以非常戏剧性的方式展示证据。他们推进来一辆装满盒子的推车，就像亚马逊快递一样。盒子又高又瘦。看起来像是有人订了一堆窗帘。我不知道里面是什么。他们带进来一连串执法人员，梳理他们那天晚上发现的所有东西，每一件物品都被作为证据提交。警察回顾了被告被逮捕和搜查时的随身摄像头录像和行车记录仪录像，警察在他们身上发现了很多东西。
[SIREN]
[警笛声]
Take this one minivan. They'd stopped this van not long after the shooting, the side windows down.
拿这辆小型货车为例。枪击发生后不久，他们就拦下了这辆货车，侧窗摇了下来。
(SUBJECT) POLICE OFFICER 2: Gun on the ground.
（对象）警察 2：枪放地上。
There's a pistol on the floor of the car. The driver, Megan Morris, has her hand on the steering wheel. She looks miserable. She's dressed all in black, long gray hair and glasses. She also has a loaded mag in her pocket.
车内地板上有把手枪。驾驶员梅根·莫里斯把手放在方向盘上。她看起来很痛苦。她全身黑衣，长长的灰发，戴着眼镜。她口袋里还有上满子弹的弹匣。
(SUBJECT) POLICE OFFICER 2: Is there any other guns in the car?
（对象）警察 2：车里还有别的枪吗？
There's some in the back seat.
后座还有一些。
(SUBJECT) POLICE OFFICER 2: In the back seat?
（对象）警察 2：在后座？
In the back seat, we see an AR-15.
在后座，我们看到了一把 AR-15。
(SUBJECT) POLICE OFFICER 2: What the fuck?
（对象）警察 2：搞什么鬼？
They're clearing the guns of ammo and piling them up on the hood of the car, one on top of the other. There's body armor, loaded magazines, another AR-15 in the trunk.
他们清理了枪支里的弹药，把枪堆在车盖上，一把叠着一把。还有防弹衣、装满弹药的弹匣、后备箱里还有另一把 AR-15。
(SUBJECT) POLICE OFFICER 2: Hey, just hang out right here. This is just like a straight, coordinated terror attack on the ICE detention facility. We got, like, six people-- trauma kits, plates, ARs, all sorts of stuff. So just hang out.
（对象）警察 2：嘿，就待在这儿。这简直就是一场针对 ICE 拘留中心的直接、有组织的恐怖袭击。我们有六个人——医疗急救包、防弹板、AR 步枪，各种东西。所以待在这儿别动。
(SUBJECT) POLICE OFFICER 3: What the fuck?
（对象）警察 3：搞什么鬼？
(SUBJECT) POLICE OFFICER 2: Bro, what the fuck, dude. This is fucking crazy.
（对象）警察 2：兄弟，搞什么鬼啊。这简直太疯狂了。
(SUBJECT) POLICE OFFICER 3: Bro, this is like a straight, coordinated terror attack on fucking Prairieland. I know, dude.
（对象）警察 3：兄弟，这简直是一场针对 Prairieland 的直接、有组织的恐怖袭击。我知道，兄弟。
This recording where the officers are like, bro, this is a terrorist attack, it was a point of contention in the trial. The defense tried to get it excluded, arguing the officers' comments could bias the jury. That's just their random opinion that this was terrorism. The judge was like, well, what they genuinely thought in the moment, seeing what they were seeing, is relevant. I'll allow it. So this is what the boxes were.
录音中警察说“兄弟，这是一场恐怖袭击”，这在庭审中是一个争议点。辩方试图将其排除在外，认为警官的评论可能会使陪审团产生偏见。那只是他们认为这是恐怖主义的个人观点。法官认为，他们在目睹现场时内心真实的想法是相关的。我准许了。所以这些就是盒子里装的东西。
Every time the officers had to introduce a new piece of evidence, they shook a gun out of a cardboard box. Guns started to pile up around the small courtroom-- semi-automatic rifles and pistols and glocks alongside body armor, trauma kits, and mags. In the top margin above my notes, I just have a star and the words "all these guns." It looks bad for the defense.
每次警察需要引入新证据时，他们就从纸板箱里抖出一把枪。法庭内开始堆积起各种枪支——半自动步枪、手枪和格洛克，还有防弹衣、医疗包和弹匣。在笔记本上方的空白处，我只画了一颗星，写着“全是这些枪”。这对辩方来说看起来很糟糕。
I also have notes on family members looking freaked out and upset. One of the sisters of a defendant keeps whispering, what's going on? Like, why isn't the defense doing more to object to all this stuff? A few stickers make it into evidence too. "Make America not exist again," one of them says.
我还记录了家属们看起来被吓坏了且很难过。其中一名被告的姐妹一直在嘀咕，发生什么事了？为什么辩方不多做点抗议，反对所有这些东西？还有几张贴纸也被作为证据提交。“让美国不再存在”，其中一张上面写着。
The defense gets up. And the way one of the lawyers explains the guns is like, come on, this is Texas. We all have these. These are all legal guns, and these people have guns for a reason. When out protesting, the lawyers argue, these guys encounter counter-protesters on the right who are armed. So they're armed. They often bring them.
辩方站了起来。其中一名律师解释枪支的方式就像是说，拜托，这是德州。我们都有这些。这些全是合法枪支，而且这些人持有枪支是有原因的。律师辩称，在外面抗议时，这些人会遇到右翼的武装反抗者。所以他们也带了武器。他们经常带着这些枪。
Most importantly, they point out, the guns in that van, they never left the van. Now, they are forced to say this while standing in a courtroom sort of ridiculously filled with firearms and ammunition. Even in Texas, this has got to be a little much. It's like an armory. One of the defense attorneys later said to me, yeah, would it have been better if they just had bells and whistles, if their intent was just to make noise? Would it have been better if they weren't dressed like they were storming the Bastille? Yes, it would have.
最重要的是，他们指出，那辆货车里的枪从没离开过货车。现在，他们被迫在挤满枪支弹药的法庭里说出这些话，显得很滑稽。即使在德州，这也有点过头了。这里简直像个军火库。后来一位辩护律师对我说，是的，如果他们的目的只是制造噪音，只带些铃铛和口哨会不会更好？如果他们不穿得像要去冲破巴士底狱一样会不会更好？是的，会更好。
This brings me to Act 2. I'm going to call Act 2 The Expert. So one of the main ways the prosecution was going to try to show this was an Antifa terrorist cell was by calling an Antifa expert to the stand. It was going to be a key moment in the trial. I reached out to the Antifa expert to talk, and the prosecutors bringing him on, and neither got back to me.
这把我带到了第二幕。我称第二幕为“专家”。所以，检方试图证明这是一场 Antifa 恐怖分子细胞袭击的主要方式之一，是传唤一名 Antifa 专家出庭作证。这将是审判中的一个关键时刻。我联系了这位 Antifa 专家想进行采访，同时也联系了传唤他的检察官，但两人都没有回复我。
But some of the defense attorneys did. They love to talk about this case, especially, as it turns out, the guy who was going to lead the cross-examination of the Antifa expert, Patrick McLain. McLain and I meet up most days after court at the hotel bar. The day he was going over his prep for the Antifa expert, we were at a nicer place, the Fort Worth Club downtown. It's members-only. You have to ring a doorbell to get in. McLain's not a member. He just has a friend who is. I find them in the back corner.
但有些辩护律师联系了我。他们很喜欢谈论这个案子，尤其是负责盘问 Antifa 专家帕特里克·麦克莱恩的那位律师。我和麦克莱恩大多数时候在每天庭审结束后在酒店酒吧碰面。他为 Antifa 专家准备盘问资料的那天，我们在一家更高档的地方，市中心的沃斯堡俱乐部。那是会员制的。你必须按门铃才能进去。麦克莱恩不是会员。他只是有一个朋友是会员。我在角落里找到了他们。
You don't need anything else?
你还需要别的吗？
I'm going to keep picking. But no, I don't [? eat meat. ?] Well, you know what? I'll have another Guinness.
我还要再点一点。但别点肉。对了，你知道吗？再给我来一杯吉尼斯啤酒。
Another Guinness?
再来一杯吉尼斯啤酒？
I'll have another Guinness, he says. Patrick McLain is as Irish, Chicagoan-looking as his name. Big and burly, 67 years old, he looks like the Marine that he is. His text messages are set to auto sign-off "Semper fi, Patrick." He's a former Republican, a devout Catholic. He has 10 kids. He's a regular at the March for Life every year.
再来一杯吉尼斯，他说。帕特里克·麦克莱恩和他名字一样，有着芝加哥爱尔兰人的长相。身材高大魁梧，67 岁，看起来就像他曾任职的那个海军陆战队老兵。他的短信自动签名是“永远忠诚，帕特里克”。他是前共和党人，虔诚的天主教徒。他有 10 个孩子。他每年都是“为生命而游行”活动的常客。
Tonight, he's also brought along his own terrorism expert, someone he plans to bring as a witness, a woman named Anne Speckhard. He and Speckhard are going to hammer out the best way to discredit the government's Antifa guy. Anne Speckhard stands out here a bit. She's definitely the only person in the Fort Worth Club with a flowery hair clip, almost counterculture-looking. She's a terrorism scholar. She studied ISIS and al-Qaeda and other groups. She's worked with the UN and NATO and other international organizations.
今晚，他还带上了自己的恐怖主义专家，他计划让她作为证人，一个叫安妮·斯佩克哈德的女人。他和斯佩克哈德打算商量出最好的办法来驳倒政府的那位 Antifa 专家。安妮·斯佩克哈德在这里显得有些突出。她绝对是沃斯堡俱乐部里唯一戴着花哨发卡的人，看起来几乎有点反文化。她是恐怖主义研究学者。她研究过 ISIS、基地组织和其他组织。她曾与联合国、北约和其他国际组织合作。
So are you going to take the stand, or are you just helping him prep for--
那你打算出庭作证，还是只是帮他准备——
Oh, I'm going to take the stand.
噢，我会出庭作证的。
OK.
好的。
Yeah, there's a 95% chance she'll take the stand. Only reason she wouldn't take the stand is if he was just totally so horrible that-- yeah, we wouldn't need you there.
是的，她有 95% 的把握会出庭作证。除非他（检方专家）表现得太糟糕，导致我们根本不需要她。
If the government's Antifa expert is so terrible that he needs no rebuttal, there'll be no need to take the stand. They don't expect that. Just while we wait for our drinks here, I'll explain who the government Antifa expert is. His name is Kyle Shideler, bald and quite literally egg-headed. He sits with the prosecution every day.
如果政府的 Antifa 专家糟糕到不需要反驳，那就不需要她出庭了。他们预计不会那样。在等待饮料的时候，我先解释一下政府的那位 Antifa 专家是谁。他叫凯尔·希德勒，秃头，看起来就是个典型的“书呆子”。他每天都和检方坐在一起。
He works for the Center for Security Policy, a think tank in DC that, truthfully, is most known for advocating conspiracy theories about Muslims. Or, I guess, if you believe those theories, then as brave truth-tellers. Shideler has advocated for the government to treat Antifa as a terrorist group, and in the last six years, Shideler has trained cops all over the country in what he calls "the Antifa threat." He's also testified before Congress. So the question is, how are they going to deal with this guy when he takes the stand?
他在华盛顿的一个智库“安全政策中心”工作，说实话，该智库最出名的是倡导有关穆斯林的阴谋论。或者，如果你相信那些理论的话，他们就是勇敢的真相揭露者。希德勒主张政府将 Antifa 视为恐怖组织，在过去六年里，希德勒在全国范围内对警察进行培训，讲述他所谓的“Antifa 威胁”。他还曾在国会作证。所以问题是，当这家伙出庭时，他们要怎么对付他？
So where are we going with this?
所以我们接下来要怎么做？
Anne Speckhard has a bunch of questions they can ask him on the stand, which he's written out. Like, how does one join Antifa? Is there a membership list? Are there dues? Is there a leadership structure? An oath? The basic stuff terrorist groups have.
安妮·斯佩克哈德写了一堆问题，可以在庭上问他。比如，怎么加入 Antifa？有会员名单吗？需要缴会费吗？有领导结构吗？有宣誓仪式吗？恐怖组织通常有的基本东西。
If you joined ISIS, back in the time of when they had their caliphate, and even now, you hold your hand up and you give your baah, your pledge of allegiance, to whoever the caliph is.
如果你加入了 ISIS，在他们拥有哈里发国的时候，甚至现在，你都要举起手，向哈里发效忠。
If you're joining a group, she says, you probably know you're joining a group. There's no group here.
她说，如果你加入一个组织，你很可能知道自己加入了某个组织。这里根本没有组织。
Can you show me the Antifa groups? I mean, if he asked me about Hamas, I can tell him how you get into Hamas, what you do when you're in Hamas, where the Hamas website is, that actually says Hamas. But with Antifa, he just talks amorphously, like these autonomous groups. But there's all kinds of autonomous groups.
你能给我展示 Antifa 的组织吗？我的意思是，如果他问我关于哈马斯的问题，我可以告诉他怎么加入哈马斯，加入哈马斯后要做什么，哈马斯的网站在哪，上面确实写着哈马斯。但对于 Antifa，他只是笼统地说，像这种自主组织。但这种自主组织到处都是。
The US government disagrees, of course, that Antifa does not meet the definition of a terrorist group. Patrick McLain announces he's going to mulch on all this and go get some shuteye. He says he's been sleeping in his Dallas office lately.
美国政府当然不同意 Antifa 不符合恐怖组织的定义。帕特里克·麦克莱恩宣布他要琢磨一下这些，然后去睡一会儿。他说他最近都睡在达拉斯的办公室里。
As though they're building the hype, the government saves their Antifa expert for the last few days of trial. Everyone watching has been waiting for him to take the stand. Finally, Kyle Shideler takes his place in the witness box. So what is Antifa, the prosecutor asks? Shideler really begins at the beginning.
就好像在蓄意炒作一样，政府把他们的 Antifa 专家留到了庭审的最后几天。所有人都等着他上台作证。最终，凯尔·希德勒坐在了证人席上。所以，Antifa 是什么？检察官问道。希德勒确实从头开始讲起。
The word "Anti-fa" is actually a contraction of sorts, he says, an abbreviated contraction, which is a common German phenomenon. It stands for "anti-fascist action," and it stems from the Weimar Republic in Germany. This goes on for quite a while. In the middle of a section about the history of fighting with the police over the autonomous squats of West Germany, the judge tries to hurry him along.
他说，“Antifa”这个词实际上是一种缩写，这是一种常见的德国现象。它代表“反法西斯行动”，起源于德国魏玛共和国。这段讲了很久。当讲到关于在西德的自主居所与警察发生冲突的历史时，法官试图催他快点讲。
"No offense to the professor," he says, "but this isn't the place for a lecture." Shideler, who's not a professor, seems incapable of following the judge's instruction not to lecture. I fill a notebook with Antifa's post-war rise, basically. Finally, we get into the present day and these defendants. Shideler ticks through the classic hallmarks that show this group is what he calls Antifa.
“冒犯教授了，”法官说，“但这地方不是讲课用的。”希德勒并不是教授，看起来无法遵循法官“不要讲课”的指示。我的笔记本上记满了关于 Antifa 战后崛起的内容。最终，我们回到了现在，回到了这些被告身上。希德勒列举了经典的特征，表明这个组织就是他所谓的 Antifa。
He talks about how, before that night, everyone communicated over Signal, an example of operational security, OPSEC. And that night, they all went out dressed in black-- another common tactic of Antifa, he says, called black bloc, originally known as der schwarze bloc, he says. The idea is, if everyone dresses in black, the police can't tell who's who or who did what. After an operation, the Antifa tactic is to take off the black clothing and blend back in, he says.
他谈到那天晚上之前，大家都是通过 Signal 进行通信的，这是操作安全（OPSEC）的一个例子。那天晚上，他们全都身穿黑衣——他说，这是 Antifa 的另一种常见策略，叫黑块（black bloc），最初被称为“der schwarze bloc”。他的意思是，如果大家都穿黑色，警察就分不清谁是谁，也不知道谁做了什么。他说，行动结束后，Antifa 的策略是脱掉黑衣服，重新融入人群。
The prosecutor mentions that one defendant had tied his long-sleeved black shirt around his waist when he was arrested a few miles away. "And that's an example of [? de-blocing, ?] if you will?" he asks. "Yes," says Shideler. "That's what I would expect to see."
检察官提到，其中一名被告在几英里外被捕时，腰间系着长袖黑衬衫。“这就是所谓的‘脱块’吗？”他问。“是的，”希德勒说，“这正是我想看到的。”
Then there's the book club. Shideler spends some time on this book club that some of the defendants were in, the Emma Goldman book club. Emma Goldman was a famous anarchist from the early 1900s. He says this is sort of an Antifa front, the above ground part of the organization. Shideler says, anytime you're a clandestine organization, that is, an organization that cannot recruit openly, like maybe they don't admit they exist, you have to find a way to recruit other people with which you have a shared ideology.
还有读书俱乐部。希德勒花了一些时间谈论被告参加的这个读书俱乐部，即埃玛·戈尔德曼读书俱乐部。埃玛·戈尔德曼是 1900 年代初著名的无政府主义者。他说这某种程度上是 Antifa 的掩护组织，是组织在地下的公开部分。希德勒说，当你是一个秘密组织，即无法公开招募成员的组织时，比如他们甚至不承认自己的存在，你必须找到一种方法来招募有共同意识形态的人。
Shideler lists off some of these zines the book club was reading, classics of an anarchist library, like "I Don't Bash Back, I Shoot First" and "Destroying White Nationalism." And what about these red and black flags found rolled up in one of the garages, the prosecutor asks?
希德勒列举了读书俱乐部正在阅读的一些小册子，比如无政府主义图书馆的经典作品，像《我不反击，我先开枪》和《摧毁白人至上主义》。那在其中一个车库里发现的卷起来的红黑旗帜又怎么说呢？检察官问。
When they introduced the flags as evidence, an FBI agent stood up with the flags to demonstrate how they'd be hung if they'd been hung, which they weren't. He waved them wildly at the jury like it was the finish line at NASCAR. Shideler explains, yes, that's an Antifa flag. The red and black is iconography related to the Spanish Civil War, when the anarchists were engaged in direct action against the fascists.
当他们把旗帜作为证据呈上时，一名 FBI 特工站起来展示如果把这些旗帜挂出来会是什么样（虽然它们从未被挂出来过）。他像在纳斯卡赛车的终点线挥旗一样，在陪审团面前疯狂地挥舞着。希德勒解释说，是的，那是 Antifa 的旗帜。红黑色是与西班牙内战相关的标志，当时无政府主义者正在针对法西斯分子进行直接行动。
Finally, it's Patrick McLain's moment. Time for cross-examination. McLain approaches, asks some questions about Shideler's credentials for this, pointing out he's never held a position at a college or a university. He's never published a peer-reviewed paper. Then he gets to this. McLain-- "There is no national leadership of Antifa, is there?"
终于，轮到帕特里克·麦克莱恩了。盘问时间到了。麦克莱恩走上前，问了一些关于希德勒资历的问题，指出他从未在学院或大学担任过职位。他从未发表过同行评审的论文。然后他切入主题。麦克莱恩问：“Antifa 没有全国领导层，对吧？”
Shideler-- "It would be inconsistent with their ideology." "Is that a no?" "It would be inconsistent with their ideology, so they do not, no." "OK. They don't have membership rolls." "It would be inconsistent with their ideology, so no." "Just for the sake of efficiency, if there is a yes or no answer, could you lead with that?" "Sure." "OK. Thank you. And no dues or hierarchy in anything that you would call Antifa, right?" "No, they're opposed to it."
希德勒：“那与他们的意识形态不一致。”“那是‘不’的意思吗？”“那与他们的意识形态不一致，所以他们没有，是的。”“好吧。他们也没有会员名册。”“那与他们的意识形态不一致，所以没有。”“为了提高效率，如果是‘是’或‘否’的问题，能不能先回答那个词？”“好的。”“好吧。谢谢。而且 Antifa 也没有会费或等级制度，对吧？”“没有，他们反对这些。”
If I were to summarize how Shideler's seeing this, I think he's saying Antifa is not a typical terrorist organization, with leaders or membership lists or headquarters, because it's anarchist. They don't like organizations. They operate as affinity groups. McLain points out, however, that none of the defendants ever refer to themselves as Antifa in their own private Signal chats. Shideler says they don't think about groups and organizations. That's what's counter to their ideology.
如果我总结希德勒的观点，我觉得他在说，Antifa 不是典型的恐怖组织，没有领导人、会员名单或总部，因为它是无政府主义的。他们不喜欢组织。他们以亲缘小组的形式运作。然而，麦克莱恩指出，没有被告在他们私下的 Signal 聊天中称自己为 Antifa。希德勒说他们不考虑团队和组织。那与他们的意识形态相反。
From McLain's point of view, that's crazy, Shideler saying the fact that they don't say they're Antifa is the proof that they're Antifa. And if there really was a plan to shoot police officers, as the government says, a plan to destroy government property with fireworks, if this plan really existed, why isn't that in the Signal chats? "Did anybody talk about harming another person?" McLain asks. Shideler says, "I would expect the discussions of that type to take place person to person and not necessarily appear in an encrypted chat."
在麦克莱恩看来，这太疯狂了，希德勒说“他们不承认自己是 Antifa”这一事实恰恰证明了他们是 Antifa。如果真的像政府所说的那样，有杀害警察的计划，有利用烟花破坏政府财产的计划，如果这个计划真的存在，为什么 Signal 聊天里没有？“有人谈论伤害他人吗？”麦克莱恩问。希德勒说：“我预计这类讨论会当面进行，而不一定会出现在加密聊天中。”
Then another defense attorney comes up and circles back to some of the other zines and stickers that have come up, like "Be gay, do crime" and "ACAB," All Cops Are Bastards. Typical Antifa, Shideler says. There was also a zine on horticulture, that attorney points out. "Foraging and horticulture, yes," says Shideler. "So what, gardening is part of the Antifa platform?" "Not as such," Shideler says, "but it's consistent with a community defense approach."
然后另一名辩护律师上台，绕回了提到的其他小册子和贴纸，比如“做同性恋，做犯罪”和“ACAB”（所有的警察都是混蛋）。希德勒说，这是典型的 Antifa。律师指出，还有一本关于园艺的小册子。“觅食和园艺，是的，”希德勒说。“那么，园艺也是 Antifa 纲领的一部分吗？”“不是那样的，”希德勒说，“但这与社区防御的方法是一致的。”
The judge speaks up. He sounds mad again. "Just because I own a copy of Mein Kampf doesn't make me a fascist or a Nazi, does it?" "Not unless it's consistent with your other behavior," Shideler says. "What if I owned a copy of Das Kapital? Does that make me a Communist?" "Not unless it's consistent with your other behavior." "What about a copy of The Vantage Point by Lyndon Johnson? Does that make me a Democrat?" "No, sir. Not unless it's consistent with your other behavior." "If I own Antifa literature, that doesn't make me an anti-fascist necessarily, does it?" "I hope not, sir. I have quite a bit of it myself."
法官开口了。他听起来又生气了。“仅仅因为我有一本《我的奋斗》，并不意味着我是法西斯分子或纳粹，对吧？”“除非这与你的其他行为相一致，”希德勒说。“如果我有一本《资本论》呢？那说明我是共产主义者吗？”“除非这与你的其他行为相一致。”“那林登·约翰逊写的《有利地点》呢？那让我成为民主党人了吗？”“不，长官。除非这与你的其他行为相一致。”“如果我拥有 Antifa 文献，并不意味着我一定就是反法西斯主义者，对吗？”“我希望不是，长官。我自己就有不少。”
The judge's impatience made Shideler's testimony play sort of ridiculous in the room, sometimes, I thought. Every so often, I look at the jury. It's a pretty mixed group, old and young, white and Hispanic, men and women, mostly expressionless, sometimes sleepy. One day, one of them came in a Darth Vader sweatshirt. Why? Who knows. I never can read them.
法官的不耐烦使得希德勒的证词在房间里显得有些荒谬，我觉得。偶尔，我会看看陪审团。这是一个非常多元的群体，有老有少，有白人和拉美裔，有男有女，大多面无表情，有时昏昏欲睡。有一天，其中一个人穿着达斯·维达的卫衣。为什么？谁知道呢。我永远看不透他们。
Outside this courtroom, the Trump administration is making all sorts of big claims about Antifa. The national security memo that instructs government agencies to treat Antifa as a domestic terror group, a major national security priority, claims Antifa is this big, organized network with institutional funders.
法庭外，特朗普政府正在就 Antifa 提出各种宏大的主张。那份指示政府机构将 Antifa 视为国内恐怖组织、作为重大国家安全优先事项的备忘录，声称 Antifa 是一个拥有机构资助者的巨大、有组织的网络。
"This violence," it says, "does not emerge organically." Presidential aide Stephen Miller has said, "It is structured, it is sophisticated, it is well-funded, it is well-planned." So it's fascinating to see that once they got to court, they dropped all that. Shideler and the government never tried to present any evidence showing some kind of national coordination or structure or planning or funding. Shideler did point to a crowdfunding Linktree at one point.
备忘录称：“这些暴力并非有机地出现。”总统助理斯蒂芬·米勒曾说：“它是结构化的、复杂的、资金充足的、规划良好的。”所以很有趣的是，一旦他们到了法庭，就把这一切都抛弃了。希德勒和政府从没试图提交任何证据表明存在某种全国性的协调、结构、规划或资助。希德勒在某一点上确实指向了一个众筹 Linktree。
Instead, what the government argues is that the defendants all do things that come from a sort of anarchist playbook-- wearing dark clothes, reading anarchist literature. And that's what makes them Antifa. The people within the group don't have to join a group, or say they're in a group, or maybe even know that they're in a group at all, to be in Antifa.
相反，政府的论点是，被告都做了某些源于无政府主义剧本的事情——穿深色衣服，阅读无政府主义文献。这就是让他们成为 Antifa 的原因。群体内的人甚至不必加入一个团体，不必说他们在一个团体中，甚至可能根本不知道自己在一个团体中，就已经身在 Antifa 了。
I walked outside. It was a beautiful Texas spring day and people are in a good mood. Across from the courthouse, there's a little demonstration in support of the defendants every day, mostly sympathetic activists and friends. A hand-painted banner that says "Show trial" is draped across the trees, and there are little tables of zines and free vegan food.
我走到了外面。那是美丽的德州春日，人们心情不错。在法院对面，每天都有一个小型的支持被告的示威活动，主要是同情的活动家和朋友。树上悬挂着一条手绘横幅，上面写着“作秀审判”，还有一些小桌子放着小册子和免费的纯素食。
When court's over, the families spill across the street to talk about what happened inside. Sometimes they feel like talking to us. Sometimes they don't. Today, Antifa expert day, they feel great. Some lawyers also felt great. They'd actually been on a high for a few days now.
庭审结束时，家属们涌向街头谈论里面发生的事情。有时他们愿意和我们交谈。有时不愿意。今天，Antifa 专家日，他们感觉很棒。一些律师也感觉很棒。他们实际上已经兴奋了好几天了。
We have half the government's case in, and we've been basically kicking their ass.
政府的案子我们听了一半，我们基本上是在打得他们落花流水。
This is Brian Bouffard. He's co-counsel to Patrick McLain on this case.
这是布莱恩·布法德。他是本案帕特里克·麦克莱恩的联合辩护律师。
You guys are pretty confident right now.
你们现在很有信心啊。
I can't even say we're confident-- because nobody knows what a jury's going to do. But my feeling is, the government has made a lot of mistakes. Their witnesses have made a lot of mistakes. And the way that that has come out, I think, is pretty favorable.
我甚至不能说很有信心——因为没人知道陪审团会怎么做。但我感觉，政府犯了很多错误。他们的证人犯了很多错误。而且事情进展到这个地步，我认为这对我们相当有利。
Brian Bouffard is a former Navy Jag. He defended someone accused of terrorism before, a prisoner at Guantanamo who'd been tortured for years at CIA black sites. He is deeply suspicious of the government, and this trial really bothers him. It's a prime example to him of the DOJ becoming a tool for punishing people who disagree with the President.
布莱恩·布法德曾是海军陆战队军法官。他之前曾为一名被指控恐怖主义的人辩护，一名在 CIA 黑狱中被折磨多年的关塔那摩囚犯。他对政府深表怀疑，这次审判让他非常困扰。对他来说，这是司法部成为惩罚异见者工具的一个绝佳例子。
I've got a lot tied up in this for me. I find the corruption of the justice system to be just horribly psychologically painful to see going on.
我在这上面投入了很多。看到司法体系的腐败正在发生，这在心理上让我感到非常痛苦。
Mhm. That you're so freaked out by what's happening to the Justice Department.
嗯。你对司法部正在发生的事情感到如此惊恐。
Freaked out is not the word. Furious is the word. What is going on right now with the Justice Department is unspeakable, in my view.
惊恐不是那个词。愤怒才是。在我看来，司法部现在发生的事情是无法言说的。
That's why he wants to win this case so badly. Now, the Antifa expert, that part went well, he thought, for his side-- so well, in fact, that they end up not calling up their own expert at all. They never put their terrorism scholar, Anne Speckhard, from the bar, on the stand. But the government had another, maybe more powerful argument for the existence of Antifa, which I'll tell you about when we come back.
这就是为什么他如此想赢得这场官司。现在，Antifa 专家那部分，他认为对他这一方进展顺利——事实上太顺利了，以至于他们最终根本没有传唤自己的专家。他们从未把那位在酒吧的恐怖主义学者安妮·斯佩克哈德请上证人席。但政府对于 Antifa 的存在还有另一个、可能更有力的论据，我会在回来后告诉你。
Zoe Chace. Coming up after the break, we hear from an alleged member of this alleged terror cell, and she seems very different from what the government says she is. That's in a minute on Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
佐伊·蔡斯。休息之后，我们将听到这个所谓恐怖组织中一名成员的自述，她看起来与政府所说的非常不同。一分钟后，当我们的节目在芝加哥公共广播电台继续播出时，为您讲述。
This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, The Test Case. We're devoting the whole hour to this first of its kind trial of people that the government says are part of an Antifa cell on charges that could send them to prison for decades. We've arrived at Act 3 of our show. Act 3, The Cooperator.
《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是《测试案》。我们将用整整一小时讲述这场史无前例的审判，被告被政府称为 Antifa 的一员，面临可能让他们入狱几十年的指控。我们来到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，合作者。
OK, so originally, 16 people were charged in this case. Nine of them went on trial. And the other seven, they pled guilty to material support to terrorists. They admitted this. In the documents that are part of their plea agreements, some of them signed statements agreeing that what happened outside the detention center was an act of terrorism carried out by an Antifa cell and the people involved that night adhered to an anarchist Antifa ideology.
好了，原本有 16 人被起诉。其中 9 人受审。另外 7 人对恐怖主义物质支持罪名认罪。他们承认了这一点。在作为认罪协议一部分的文件中，他们中的一些人签署了声明，同意拘留中心外发生的事情是由 Antifa 组织实施的恐怖主义行为，且当晚参与的人遵循无政府主义 Antifa 意识形态。
That, of course, seemed good for the government's case. Also, five of them appeared in court to testify for the prosecution. One of the five in particular stood out to Zoe. This was a woman named Lynette Sharp. She was older than a lot of the others, 57 years old. And just to say what her involvement was in all this, she was not at the detention center that night.
这当然对政府的案子有利。此外，其中 5 人出庭为检方作证。其中一人特别让佐伊印象深刻。她叫琳内特·夏普。她比其他人大得多，57 岁。说明一下她在这件事中的参与程度，她那天晚上并不在拘留中心。
She had planned to go, but then she couldn't make it. But remember how the guy who shot the cop hid in a sunflower field the whole night and then eventually got snuck out by a couple friends? That was Lynette. She fished him out of the field and then hid him from the cops. The authorities tracked her down a few days later, arrested her. She's been locked up since. And she agreed to talk to Zoe. Again, here's Zoe Chace.
她本打算去的，但后来没去成。但还记得那个在向日葵田里躲了一整晚，最后被几个朋友偷运出来的开枪打中警察的家伙吗？那是琳内特做的。她把他从地里钓出来，然后把他藏起来躲避警察。当局几天后追踪到了她并将其逮捕。她从此就被关押起来。她同意和佐伊谈谈。再次说明，这是佐伊·蔡斯。
When the cooperators appeared in court, they were brought in prison stripes. They mostly seemed to be in some degree of anguish over what they were doing, testifying against their friends. It was hard to sit through. There was something about Lynette, though. She was chatty. It seemed like she couldn't help it, kind of. She knew so much about these people's lives.
当合作者们出现在法庭上时，他们穿着囚服。对于他们正在做的事，即指证自己的朋友，他们大多显得有些痛苦。这很难看完。但琳内特有些特别。她很爱说话。感觉好像她忍不住一样。她太了解这些人的生活了。
At one point, she had said that three of the defendants were in a throuple-- not a word I expected to hear in the Northern District of Texas, I guess. But then also, when the prosecutor had her ID the defendants, one by one, she broke down in tears. They were lined up right in front of her. "I love them," she said to the prosecutor.
有一次，她提到三名被告是一夫二妻制的“三角恋”关系——在德州北部，我真没料到会听到这个词。但后来，当检察官让她逐一辨认被告时，她泪流满面。他们就在她面前排成一排。“我爱他们，”她对检察官说。
So I went to talk to her. I wanted to know what this group might have looked like on the inside, and I wanted to know how she'd gotten to this point in her life, pleading guilty to a terrorism charge. I drove out there with her lawyer, Erin. You go through a bunch of nothing, and then there's the jail-- long, low buildings, barbed wire around, a couple Texas flags flying. And Erin takes me inside.
所以我去和她谈了。我想知道这个组织内部是什么样，我想知道她是如何走到这一步，承认恐怖主义指控的。我和她的律师艾琳一起开车去那里。你穿过一片虚无，然后就到了监狱——长长的、低矮的建筑，周围有铁丝网，飘扬着几面德州州旗。艾琳带我进去了。
Hello!
你好！
Can I help y'all?
能帮到你们吗？
I am here for an attorney visit to see Ms. Lynette Sharp, and she's with me.
我是来探视琳内特·夏普女士的律师，她是和我一起的。
They lead us into a small room. There's a big, clear plastic divider cutting it down the middle. A guard opens the door on the other side of the divider and brings Lynette in. She's in the orange and white prison stripes. There was a small speaker stuck into the plastic that we talked through.
他们把我们带到一个小房间。中间有一块大的、透明的塑料隔板。隔板另一边的守卫打开门，把琳内特带了进来。她穿着橙白相间的囚服。塑料板上嵌着一个小扬声器，我们通过它谈话。
Hey.
嘿。
Hi.
嗨。
I want to ask how you are.
我想问你还好吗。
You know, I can't complain. If I did, who would listen?
你知道，我没什么可抱怨的。如果我抱怨，谁会听呢？
Well, I'm asking.
好吧，我在问你啊。
I'm OK.
我还好。
I had my mic pointed at the wrong part of the speaker. It'll get better later. Sorry about that. When Lynette was arrested, she had spiky pink hair. Now it's a gray ponytail. She has glasses and hearing aids.
我把麦克风对准了扬声器的错误位置。后面会好起来的。很抱歉。琳内特被捕时，留着粉色的刺猬头。现在扎着灰色的马尾。她戴着眼镜和助听器。
I have to say, I talk to people a lot about their politics for my job. Why do you believe the things you do? It's never simple. It's built over their lifetime. There's not one thing that leads you to it. I feel like I need to do something a little unusual here, which is tell you Lynette's story from the beginning. So I want to start this part of the story here, alleged Antifa cell terrorist at age five.
我必须说，我因为工作原因经常和人们聊他们的政治立场。为什么你会相信你所相信的东西？这从来都不简单。它是在你的一生中建立起来的。没有哪一件事会直接导致这一切。我觉得我需要在这里做一件稍微不寻常的事，就是从头开始讲述琳内特的故事。所以我想要从这个故事开始讲述：五岁时的 Antifa 组织恐怖分子。
Lynette grew up outside Fort Worth in the early '70s. She was a tomboy, played dirt clod wars in the streets. She rode bikes and the neighbor's horses. She liked being out of the house because the situation in the house wasn't good. Her parents fought a lot, drank a lot. They even tried to kill each other a couple of times. Her mom shot her dad-- twice. He survived.
琳内特 70 年代初在沃斯堡郊外长大。她是个假小子，在街上玩泥巴仗。她骑自行车和邻居的马。她喜欢待在屋外，因为屋里的情况不好。她父母经常打架，经常喝酒。他们甚至还几次试图杀死对方。她母亲枪击了她父亲——两次。他幸存了下来。
She tried to poison him several times, too. My parents were fighters. And that's where I get my fighting spirit, I think.
她也几次试图毒死他。我的父母是斗士。我想这就是我的战斗精神来源。
Wow.
哇。
And so--
所以——
How did she try to poison him? And how did you even know that happened?
她是怎么试图毒死他的？你怎么知道这件事发生的？
My mother never hid anything from us. She used Miracle-Gro and put it in his beer. It didn't work. And I don't remember what she used the other time.
我母亲从不向我们隐瞒任何事。她用奇迹肥料放在他的啤酒里。没起作用。我不记得另一次她用了什么。
Lynette didn't want to stick around. She got together with this guy and moved out of state, and they had a kid together. But it was a similar relationship to her mom and dad's, as much as she thought she was nothing like them, she was feeling sort of "Miracle-Gro in his beer" herself. It scared her. She moved back with her parents, moved out again, and eventually left that guy.
琳内特不想待在那里。她和一个男人在一起，搬到了州外，他们生了一个孩子。但那是一段和她父母如出一辙的关系，尽管她认为自己一点也不像他们，她自己也感觉像是“啤酒里的奇迹肥料”。这让她很害怕。她搬回父母那里，又搬了出去，最终离开了那个男人。
At this point, she gets really into church. Something about it really appealed to her, being part of a group, maybe because, she says, she just never felt a part of her family at all. And Lynette is a people person. This is the first big group that she dives into-- the church.
此时，她开始沉迷于教会。某种东西真正吸引了她，成为一个团体的一部分，可能是因为她说，她从来没感到自己是家庭的一部分。而且琳内特是个“交际花”。这是她投身进去的第一个大团体——教会。
I went to church constantly. I found a church and was there every time the doors were open and just really immersed myself in that.
我不断地去教堂。我找了一个教堂，每次教堂开门我就去，真的全身心投入其中。
It was Pentecostal, but women could wear pants, which she liked. Things calmed. She met another guy, a clean, non-abusive, nice guy named Marshall. Nerdy-- played Dungeons and Dragons and video games. They got married, and at first, she says it was great.
那是五旬节派，但女性可以穿裤子，她很喜欢这一点。事情平静了下来。她遇到了另一个男人，一个干净、不虐待人、好人，叫马歇尔。书呆子——玩《龙与地下城》和电子游戏。他们结婚了，起初，她说这很棒。
But slowly, even though this was a really different relationship from her first one, it also began to feel like a trap to Lynette. She already had one kid, then her husband's kids came to live with them and she got pregnant. And right then, her husband kind of disappeared into his computer.
但慢慢地，尽管这与她的第一段关系完全不同，但对琳内特来说，这也开始感觉像个陷阱。她已经有一个孩子了，然后她丈夫的孩子也来和他们住，她怀孕了。就在那时，她丈夫钻进电脑里消失了。
And that's when it got to be too much. I started really having a hard time with everything.
那时候一切变得太过分了。我开始对一切感到很困难。
She called the pastor's wife for advice.
她给牧师的妻子打电话求建议。
She did tell me-- when I told her what was going on, she said, why are you doing all of this? Because I was doing everything. And she said, why aren't they doing this and that? They can do their own laundry. They can make their own lunches. And I'm like, I just thought that's what I was supposed to be doing. And she said, no.
当告诉她发生了什么事时，她确实对我说，你为什么要做所有这些？因为我做了所有事。她说，为什么他们不做这做那？他们可以自己洗衣服。他们可以自己做午饭。我说，我只是以为那是我就该做的。她说，不。
Like, that's what the housewife does, kind of thing.
就像家庭主妇该做的事情，那种感觉。
Yes. And so she kind of gave me permission to say, hey, I'm not doing this anymore.
是的。所以她给了我许可，说，嘿，我不做了。
After that, she says, they started living separate lives side by side. There are many more dramatic chapters of Lynette's life lived in these bright, intense strokes. Her daughter gets pregnant at 16. She figures out that one of her stepkids is abusing her daughters. Eventually, her stepson is arrested.
那之后，她说，他们开始过着各自侧面平行但独立的生活。琳内特的生活中还有更多戏剧性的篇章，以这种明亮、强烈的笔触书写。她女儿 16 岁怀孕了。她发现其中一个继子女在虐待她的女儿。最终，继子被捕了。
She ends up taking in a kid who's severely autistic and raising them. And Lynette and her husband come together to deal with these crises and then grow apart again. They get close for a while when they join a new group. Of all things, it's a motorcycle club.
她最终收养了一个重度自闭症的孩子并抚养长大。琳内特和她丈夫聚在一起处理这些危机，然后又分开了。当他们加入一个新团体时，他们又亲近了一段时间。不管你信不信，那是摩托车俱乐部。
This is another turning point. Lynette gets really into the motorcycle club. It was a motorcycle club of Marines. Her husband served in the Marines. And he got really into it, too. It kind of got him out of his depression.
这是另一个转折点。琳内特迷上了摩托车俱乐部。那是一个海军陆战队的摩托车俱乐部。她丈夫在海军陆战队服役。他也迷上了这个。这有点让他走出了抑郁。
And it helped him a lot, made him want to be a more functioning person, for them and for me. And then for the X-rated portion of our show, we found out that we liked different sex than we'd been having. [LAUGH]
这对他帮助很大，让他想成为一个更正常的人，为了他们也为了我。然后为了我们节目的成人部分，我们发现我们喜欢与之前不同的性生活。[笑]
You found that out together?
你们一起发现的？
It was kind of-- it was a weird thing. A lady in the club posted something on Facebook about something about a sexual thing, and I commented on it, and Marshall texted me immediately and said, did you mean that? And I said, yes. And so we started talking. And that made us realize we'd been having sex wrong the whole time.
这有点——那是一件奇怪的事。俱乐部里的一位女士在 Facebook 上发布了一些关于性的东西，我评论了它，马歇尔立刻给我发短信问，你是认真的吗？我说，是的。于是我们开始谈论。那让我们意识到我们一直以来性生活都过错了。
I mean, I want to ask what you mean, but you don't have to get into it.
我是想问你什么意思，但你不必深入说明。
We like sex that wasn't vanilla.
我们喜欢不寻常的性生活。
Right. You like more hardcore things.
没错。你们喜欢更激进的事情。
Yeah.
是的。
And you found that out because this woman posted something, and you commented, and he texted you.
你们发现这一点是因为那个女人发布了些什么，你评论了，然后他发短信给你。
Yes.
是的。
Wow. Facebook.
哇。Facebook。
Yes.
是的。
Lynette was still going to church, but now in her Sons of Anarchy t-shirt. They didn't know what to make of her. In Lynette's next chapter of self-realization-- maybe you saw this coming-- she's watching Amber Heard in this movie The Rum Diary, and realizes, actually, she's always liked girls. And she gives Marshall an ultimatum.
琳内特还在去教堂，但现在穿着她的《混乱之子》T 恤。他们不知道该拿她怎么办。在琳内特接下来的自我实现篇章里——也许你预见到了——她在看那部电影《朗姆酒日记》里的艾梅柏·希尔德，意识到其实她一直喜欢女孩。她给马歇尔下了最后通牒。
Either I can smoke weed in the garage or we're having an open relationship, one of those, because I'm losing my mind here. I need relief. I need, like, fun.
要么我在车库里抽大麻，要么我们维持开放式关系，二选一，因为我快疯了。我需要解脱。我需要，就像，乐趣。
He wasn't happy with either option at first, but then he got what she was asking.
他起初对两个选择都不满意，但后来他明白了她的要求。
Really, I want to explore having sex with women. I've never been able to explore my sexuality in that way. And he said, well, that's fine. Because men. Because men.
真的，我想探索和女性发生关系。我从来没能以那种方式探索我的性取向。他说，好吧，那没问题。因为男人。因为男人。
Yeah.
是的。
And so then we would go out on dates and look at women together. [LAUGH]
所以我们就一起出去约会，一起看女人。[笑]
That was a high point. Lynette is a person who goes all the way when she's into something. But however hot Amber Heard is in The Rum Diary, in Lynette's mind, Lynette is still a church lady in suburban Texas. She's a conservative. At this point in Lynette's story, it's 2011, 2012, and she's paying more attention to the news now more than she used to. And Barack Obama is running for office again.
那是高潮。琳内特是一个全身心投入某件事的人。但不管艾梅柏·希尔德在《朗姆酒日记》里有多火辣，在琳内特心里，她依然是德州郊区的教会女士。她是保守派。在琳内特的故事这一节点，时间是 2011 年、2012 年，她现在比以前更加关注新闻。巴拉克·奥巴马再次竞选公职。
I remember when Obama was elected for the second time, I cried. I thought we were all going to be under Sharia law any time. Like, so many people in my life felt that way. And the Pizzagate stuff was going on then. And--
我记得奥巴马第二次当选时，我哭了。我想我们随时都会进入伊斯兰教法之下。就像我生命中很多人那样觉得。当时还有“披萨门”的事情。然后——
Did you believe in that?
你相信那个吗？
I did.
我相信。
Lynette didn't like Trump either, though, things like the "grab them by the pussy" tape. No thank you. And it wasn't long before basically, presidential politics kind of caught up to her personal politics. Which is true for a lot of people, right? National politics became intertwined with people's actual identities. The MeToo movement was a thing for her. Oh, and also around then--
不过，琳内特也不喜欢特朗普，比如那段“抓住她们的私处”录音。不需要，谢谢。没过多久，总统政治基本上就追上了她个人的政治观。这对很多人来说是真的，对吧？全国政治与人们真实的身份认同交织在一起。“MeToo”运动对她来说是一回事。噢，还有大约那时——
I went to college. Forgot that part.
我上大学了。忘了那部分。
Then there's the repeal of Roe v. Wade. That happened. She was fighting with her friends and family over it.
然后就是撤销“罗诉韦德案”。那发生了。她为了这事和朋友家人吵架。
When Roe v. Wade, they were going to get rid of Roe v. Wade. And I knew it. And I knew it was coming. And then I'm like, this is bad. And people were like, you're just blowing it all up out of proportion.
当“罗诉韦德案”，他们要废除它的时候。我预料到了。我知道它要来了。然后我就想，这太糟糕了。人们说，你只是把一切都夸大了。
But you were starting to find yourself on a little bit of a different planet than the people around you.
但你开始发现自己处于一个与周围人稍微不同的星球上了。
Yes.
是的。
In 2022, she started going to protests for the first time. There's something very "only in America" about Lynette's life, I think-- how fast it moved, how many eras she went through, embodying each one. I kept thinking of this old article from Ms. Magazine from 1972 by Jane O'Reilly. It was called "Click, The Housewife's Moment of Truth," about all these realizations women were having about things they didn't actually have to do. "We are all housewives. We would prefer to be persons," the article said, a year before Roe.
在 2022 年，她第一次参加了抗议活动。我认为琳内特的生活中有一种非常“只有在美国”的东西——它推进得有多快，她经历了多少个时代，每个时代都体现了出来。我一直想起简·奥赖利 1972 年在《Ms.》杂志上写的一篇老文章。题目叫“点击，家庭主妇的真理时刻”，关于女性开始意识到的那些她们不必非做不可的事情。“我们都是家庭主妇。我们宁愿做一个人，”文章说，那是在“罗案”前一年。
Lynette was that housewife. Click. Decades later, here she is on her own motorcycle, checking out girls with her husband. And then Roe is struck down, and it feels personal. Lynette has come to truly hate the idea of men controlling women. That's how she saw it. It's around this time when she finds her last club.
琳内特就是那个家庭主妇。点击。几十年后，她在这里骑着自己的摩托车，和丈夫一起看女人。然后“罗案”被推翻了，这感觉很私人。琳内特开始真正讨厌男人控制女人的想法。这就是她所看到的。大约在这个时候，她找到了最后一个俱乐部。
It's a group of people in the Dallas Fort Worth area. She meets them through a local LGBT center. They do self-defense classes. Some of them are in a book club, the Emma Goldman book club, where they read radical literature and zines. Many of them are part of a local gun club, the Socialist Rifle Association, where they do target practice and learn about gun safety. Soon, she was spending most of her time with them.
那是达拉斯沃斯堡地区的一群人。她通过当地的 LGBT 中心认识了他们。他们做自卫训练。他们中有一些在读书俱乐部，即埃玛·戈尔德曼读书俱乐部，在那里阅读激进文献和小册子。他们中许多人是当地枪支俱乐部“社会主义步枪协会”的一部分，在那里进行打靶练习并学习枪支安全。很快，她大部分时间都和他们在一起。
How did that happen, that they became your closest friends?
这是怎么发生的，他们成为了你最好的朋友？
Well, they were the ones that-- in person, life. I mean, I didn't have a job. A lot of these people didn't have jobs. We don't love capitalism, and a lot of them are so very neurodivergent that they just couldn't work. And a lot of them were younger. And yeah, it felt like-- it felt amazing to know that there were other people that actually cared about something other than themselves, that were willing to help other people for free. I mean, they gave their time. We helped the homeless. We helped disabled people. I would lead meditations, because I was-- I love meditation. And they taught me how to eat vegan food that wasn't horrible.
好吧，他们是——在现实生活中。我的意思是，我没有工作。很多人没有工作。我们不爱资本主义，而且他们中许多人非常神经多样性，以至于他们根本无法工作。他们许多人更年轻。是的，这种感觉——知道还有人在意除了自己以外的东西，愿意免费帮助他人，这种感觉太棒了。我的意思是，他们贡献了自己的时间。我们帮助无家可归者。我们帮助残疾人。我负责带领冥想，因为我是——我热爱冥想。他们教会了我如何吃不难吃的纯素食。
This, of course, is the alleged Antifa cell that's on trial. There were so many ways to be in a group in this group. And Lynette loves groups, like that gun club, for instance. A few people in the group were transgender. There was a sort of ethos around, if people who hate us have guns, we're going to have guns. Lynette got super into that, joined the member Welfare Committee. Lynette also joined a writing group. They called themselves the resistance writers. They had a lot of potlucks, obviously, and karaoke nights.
这当然就是受审的所谓 Antifa 细胞。在这个组织里，成为一员有很多种方式。琳内特热爱团体，比如那个枪支俱乐部。团体中有几个人是跨性别者。周围有一种理念，即如果恨我们的人有枪，那我们也要有枪。琳内特非常沉迷于此，加入了会员福利委员会。琳内特还加入了一个写作小组。他们自称“抵抗作家”。他们显然有很多聚餐和卡拉 OK 之夜。
What did you sing?
你唱了什么？
Oh, the best times we had. I sang everything. I sang so many things. I love P!nk. "Wild Hearts Can't Be Broken." I told them that used to be-- I think a lot of people think that. And I used it as a song from, like, in a personal relationship. But to me, it was, like, my love song to the world, that we're not going to be broken, that we're going to keep fighting. And if you look at the lyrics, it's a great song.
噢，我们度过的最棒的时光。我什么都唱。我唱了很多东西。我爱 P!nk。《野心无法被粉碎》。我告诉他们那曾经是——我想很多人都这么认为。我把它用作一首歌，就像，在个人关系中。但对我来说，它就像是我给世界的情歌，我们不会被打垮，我们会继续战斗。如果你看看歌词，那是一首很棒的歌。
It was like she was having a sort of love affair, but with a bunch of ideas. One person in particular she grew really close to was Ben Song, whom everyone called Champagne. Song, Champagne, went by any/all pronouns with this group of people. During the trial, most people used he/him, including his lawyer, and I'll do the same.
就像她经历了一场恋爱，但对象是一堆理念。她特别亲近的一个人是本·宋，大家都叫他“香槟”。宋，香槟，这群人对他用任何/所有代词。在庭审期间，大多数人对他使用“他”，包括他的律师，我也一样。
In this group, a lot of people looked up to him. He was really into self-defense. He taught martial arts to many of them. He taught gun safety to many of them with the Socialist Rifle Association. He went to a lot of protests. He'd been in the Marines. He was soft-spoken, but very confident. Song was the one that night who would fire the shot that hit the police officer.
在这个团体中，许多人仰望他。他非常热衷于自卫。他教了他们许多人武术。他通过社会主义步枪协会教了他们许多人枪支安全。他参加了很多抗议活动。他曾在海军陆战队服役。他说话声音轻柔，但非常自信。那天晚上，宋就是开枪击中警察的那个人。
What was your relationship like with Ben, with Champagne?
你和本、和香槟的关系怎么样？
It was very close. I remember telling him that he was my best friend in all this shit that we were going through.
非常亲密。我记得告诉过他，在我们经历的这所有狗屎事中，他是我最好的朋友。
Really?
真的吗？
I know that I wasn't his best friend, but I don't know. I just felt very close to him. I admired him. I respected him a lot. He wasn't a perfect person. Going to their house, it was a mess. These kids are-- and I do think of them as kids a lot. I don't mean to.
我知道我不是他最好的朋友，但我不知道。我只是感觉和他非常亲近。我钦佩他。我非常尊重他。他不是一个完美的人。去他们家，那里一团糟。这些孩子是——我确实经常把他们当作孩子。我不是故意的。
I don't mean to denigrate them or anything, but they were-- I learned so much from them. But at the same time, they're so young, and sometimes, their lives weren't working very well. And so it's a lot easier, sometimes, to focus on the world's problems than your own.
我不是故意贬低他们，但他们是——我从他们身上学到了很多。但与此同时，他们太年轻了，有时，他们的生活并不顺利。所以，关注世界的问题比关注你自己的问题要容易得多。
Yeah.
是的。
And so I did that a lot, I think. I think a lot of us did.
所以我确实经常那样做。我想我们中许多人都那样做了。
Lynette was investing so much in this group of people and pulling away from the family stuff that frustrated her, like finding services for her autistic kid, for instance. She tried and tried, and it kept not working. She stopped trying. She and her husband were back to living separate lives.
琳内特对这些人投入了太多，并远离了让她沮丧的家庭事务，例如为她的自闭症孩子寻找服务。她试了又试，却总是不行。她放弃了。她和丈夫又回到了分居的生活。
I remember I was on the way home from something, like, at 2:00 in the morning, one night, and I was thinking about what I was doing the next day, some other thing we were going to do, and I was like, for the first time in my life, I'm doing what I want to do with my time. I'd never really been free like that before. And it didn't last long, did it?
我记得有一次，凌晨两点在回家的路上，我在想第二天要做什么，一些其他我们要去做的事情，我就想，我人生中第一次在按照自己的意愿支配时间。我之前从来没有真正自由过。但那没持续多久，对吧？
Now we're at that night, July 4, 2025, when everything happened, Lynette had been in some of the Signal chats where people were making plans. But that night, her husband and her daughter were fighting, some kind of a breakdown. Felt like she needed to be at home. She was awake when people started messaging, trying to figure out what had happened. She heard people had gotten arrested. She heard a cop had been shot.
现在到了那天晚上，2025 年 7 月 4 日，发生了一切。琳内特曾参加过人们策划计划的一些 Signal 聊天。但那天晚上，她丈夫和女儿在吵架，某种崩溃。她觉得她需要在家。当人们开始发信息试图弄清楚发生了什么时，她还醒着。她听说有人被捕了。她听说一个警察被枪击了。
On one hand, I must have known, but I didn't know. I think I'd already read the reports that were out saying there'd been a-- but I just didn't believe it.
一方面，我一定知道，但我确实不知道。我想我已经读过报道，说有一个——但我就是不相信。
An officer-involved shooting.
警察参与的枪击事件。
Yeah, I just thought-- and I didn't know. I just knew I needed to go, so if I could help anyone, I wanted to go help.
是的，我只是想——而且我不知道。我只知道我需要去，所以如果我能帮到任何人，我想去帮忙。
I guess I just have a hard time understanding why it was so unbelievable if he did have a gun there. Like, isn't that sort of-- it is believable that he would shoot someone if he had a gun, right?
我想我只是很难理解，如果他当时确实带了枪，为什么会那么不可思议。我的意思是，那不是——他如果带了枪就开枪打人，这是可信的，对吧？
If he did, it was because of something had happened. Either it was like unavoidable. I didn't know. I just knew that I couldn't imagine that happening for no reason. There had to have been something that went wrong.
如果他这样做了，那是因为发生了什么。要么是不可避免的。我不知道。我只是知道我无法想象无缘无故发生那种事。一定有什么地方出错了。
Then the next day, Lynette gets a message from Song. He was still hiding in the sunflower fields near the detention facility. Could she help get him out? He had his phone in a Faraday bag, which blocks your cell phone signal so you can't be tracked. A lot of defendants brought those that night, which was more evidence the prosecution pointed to that they were a terrorist cell. Ben kept taking his phone out to message Lynette, which, I have to say, does defeat the point of the bag.
第二天，琳内特收到了宋的信息。他还躲在拘留设施附近的向日葵田里。她能帮他离开吗？他把手机装在一个法拉第袋里，那会屏蔽手机信号，这样你就不会被追踪。那天晚上很多被告都带了那个，这是检方指控他们是恐怖组织的更多证据。本不断取出手机给琳内特发信息，我不得不说，这确实违背了使用法拉第袋的目的。
I knew, and he told me, I've done a very dangerous thing. And I said, I know. I love you, friend.
我知道，他也告诉我了，我做了一件非常危险的事。我说，我知道。我爱你，朋友。
Why do you think he messaged you in particular?
你为什么认为他特别给你发了信息？
I don't know. I think because he knew that I would be there for him, that I felt kind of unanchored in my own life, that I pretty much lived for the cause or for my friends, and that I would help him.
我不知道。我想是因为他知道我会对他不离不弃，知道我在自己的生活中感觉像个没锚的船，我几乎是为了事业或为了朋友而活，我会帮他。
Lynette and this other guy pick up Song at the side of the road. He's dirty, he's hungry, dehydrated, freaked out, doesn't know where to go. Lynette and some others helped get him set up in an apartment someone was cat sitting in.
琳内特和另一个人在路边接到了宋。他很脏，很饿，脱水，吓坏了，不知道去哪儿。琳内特和其他人帮他在一个看房的公寓里安顿下来。
I mean, of course, at that point, we knew we were doing something very, very dangerous and very wrong. I don't know why we thought we could get away with it. But then I went home after that, and for the next four days, I don't think I did much of anything. I just laid in bed, and-- I don't remember.
我的意思是，当然，在那个时候，我们知道我们在做一件非常、非常危险且错误的事。我不知道为什么我们以为能逃脱惩罚。但那之后我回家了，接下来的四天里，我想我什么都没做。我只是躺在床上，而且——我不记得了。
Did you know, in those four days, like, oh, my time, this community, this chapter, this era, is over?
在那四天里，你知道，噢，我的时光，这个团体，这个篇章，这个时代，结束了吗？
I don't know. I really, really wasn't thinking. I know that sounds crazy, but I just think I disassociated for most of the four days.
我不知道。我真的，真的没在思考。我知道听起来很疯狂，但我认为那四天里我大部分时间都在解离。
Eventually, they came-- law enforcement-- raided her house, arrested her. It was dramatic. She says they rolled a big tank-like thing up onto her lawn. Lynette was charged with providing material support to terrorists. In jail, she faced a big decision.
最终，他们来了——执法人员——突袭了她的家，逮捕了她。那非常戏剧性。她说他们把一个类似坦克的大家伙开到了她的草坪上。琳内特被指控为恐怖分子提供物质支持。在监狱里，她面临一个重大决定。
Should she cooperate, plead guilty, and help the government? That would give her the best chance of a shorter sentence. Of course, that would go against everything she and her activist friends were all about, to talk to the feds. But of course, there was another huge consideration, one that actually surprised her after she got arrested.
她应该合作、认罪并帮助政府吗？那会给她最好的机会获得较短的刑期。当然，那会违背她和她的抗议者朋友们所坚持的一切，即与联邦当局谈话。但当然，还有另一个巨大的考量，一个在她被捕后确实让她感到惊讶的考量。
All this affected my family a lot more than I thought it would. We'd all been so distant for so long I kind of felt like I was-- they wouldn't miss me much. That turned out not to be true.
这一切影响我的家庭比我想象的要大得多。我们大家疏远太久了，我一直觉得我——他们不会太想我。事实证明那不是真的。
Lynette's family both needed and wanted her back. Her husband, Marshall, was devastated. Her daughter was suicidal. Her autistic kid was moved to Austin to live with her other daughter.
琳内特的家人既需要也想要她回来。她丈夫马歇尔崩溃了。她女儿有自杀倾向。她的自闭症孩子被搬到奥斯汀去和她另一个女儿住。
And they were fighting. And it was just really chaos at home.
他们在吵架。家里简直是一团混乱。
She was despondent over what to do. And I just was in my cell just going over, I can't do this. I can't talk. I can't plead. I can't-- I'd be a snitch. I'd be a traitor. My family was begging me to do it.
她对该怎么办感到灰心丧气。我当时在牢房里一直想着，我做不到。我不能说。我不能认罪。我不能——我会成为告密者。我会成为叛徒。我的家人求我这么做。
She tried to channel in her head what Song would say. And where she finally ended up is that she thought he would understand what she had to do. She had to get out of as much trouble as she could. So Lynette's lawyer started to talk with the government about a plea deal, and Lynette was fine with talking about all the details of that night, everything she had done. But there was one sticking point.
她试图在脑海中重现宋会说的话。她最终得出的结论是，她认为他会理解她必须做的事。她必须尽可能摆脱麻烦。所以琳内特的律师开始与政府谈论认罪协议，琳内特很乐意谈论那天晚上的所有细节，她所做的一切。但有一个卡点。
At what point did they start talking to you about Antifa, and what did you make of that?
他们什么时候开始和你谈论 Antifa 的，你对此怎么看？
Right away. And I'm like, I am anti-fascist. I said, there's no group called Antifa. I said, but I am anti-fascist. I said, I don't like fascists. And if you do, well-- I think that's when Erin interrupted me. [LAUGH] Because I was about to call him a fascist.
马上。我说，我是反法西斯主义者。我说，没有一个组织叫 Antifa。我说，但我确实是反法西斯主义者。我说，我不喜欢法西斯分子。如果你喜欢，好吧——我想就在那时艾琳打断了我。[笑] 因为我正要叫他法西斯分子。
Erin, Lynette's lawyer, was there during all these little talks. The government seemed fixated on getting her to say she'd been part of an Antifa cell. They proposed the following language. "Lynette Reed Sharp adhered to an Antifa, revolutionary, anarchist, or autonomous Marxist ideology that is anti-law enforcement, anti-immigration enforcement, and calls for the overthrow of the US government, law enforcement authorities, and system of law. Antifa is a militant enterprise." One cooperator did agree to that, and in fact, read it out loud in the courtroom. Lynette was like, no way. I'm not going to lie. I'm not going to perjure myself.
艾琳，琳内特的律师，在这些小谈话中都在场。政府似乎执着于让她说她是 Antifa 细胞的一员。他们提出了以下措辞。“琳内特·里德·夏普遵循一种 Antifa、革命性、无政府主义或自主马克思主义意识形态，这种意识形态是反执法、反移民执法，并呼吁推翻美国政府、执法当局和法律体系。Antifa 是一个激进组织。”一名合作者确实同意了这一点，事实上，在法庭上大声读了出来。琳内特心想，绝不可能。我不会撒谎。我不会作伪证。
We weren't a terrorist group. It was really just a protest. It was a noise demonstration, which I told them from the very beginning that there's no Antifa group, that we're just a group of friends that we're going to protest.
我们不是恐怖组织。那真的只是抗议。那是噪音示范，我从一开始就告诉他们，没有 Antifa 组织，我们只是要去抗议的一群朋友。
Yes, they read anarchist zines and philosophy and went to a shooting range, and they were serious about it. But at the same time, Lynette says there was some element of playing dressup to the whole thing with all the accoutrement that went along with it. The government proposed new language about Antifa cells. Lynette and her lawyer again said no.
是的，他们读无政府主义小册子和哲学，去了射击场，他们是认真的。但与此同时，琳内特说，整个事情中带有一些装扮游戏的成分，还有伴随而来的所有装备。政府提出了关于 Antifa 细胞的新措辞。琳内特和她的律师再次拒绝了。
Here's the language they finally ended up with. "Lynette Sharp adhered to an anti-fascist, anti-ICE anti-government ideology--" she was fine with that part-- quote, "which the government classifies as Antifa." So she's not saying there was an Antifa or that she was part of it. But she agrees that the government thinks there is. No other cooperator's plea agreement is so pointed.
这是他们最终确定的措辞。“琳内特·夏普遵循一种反法西斯、反 ICE、反政府的意识形态——”她对那部分没意见——引述，“政府将其归类为 Antifa。”所以她没说有 Antifa 或她是其中的一员。但她同意政府认为有。没有其他合作者的认罪协议是如此明确的。
As part of the deal, she'd get a maximum of 15 years in prison and wouldn't be charged with anything other than material support. She could maybe get a lower sentence recommendation from the government to the judge, depending on how helpful her testimony was to their case. The day she was taken into court to testify, Lynette was completely on her own. The bailiff let her in with a chain around her waist.
作为交易的一部分，她最高会被判处 15 年监禁，而且除了物质支持外不会被指控任何其他罪名。根据她对政府案子的帮助程度，她或许能从政府那里获得给法官的从轻量刑建议。她被带到法庭作证的那天，琳内特完全是孤身一人。法警让她腰间带着锁链进去了。
What was it like to walk into the courtroom and see them?
走进法庭看到他们是什么感觉？
Oh, it was hard. I mean, I couldn't see them very well when they were seated. I could see Song immediately. And I could tell from his face that he just didn't hate me. His face-- I felt like he was definitely trying to convey to me that he was-- he didn't hate me. He was very open-faced, very smiling, very-- and no one else had any emotion.
噢，那很难。我的意思是，他们坐着的时候我看不清。我立刻就能看到宋。我能从他的脸上看出他并没有恨我。他的脸——我觉得他肯定是在试图向我传达他——他不恨我。他表情非常开放，非常微笑，非常——而且其他人没有任何情绪。
And then I got emotional, of course. And then the prosecutor asked, you're getting emotional. Why is that? I'm like, because I love them. And he said, they're your friends. And I said, yes. And if I'd have been quick on my feet, I would have said, probably not anymore. I didn't think about that until after. But it was emotional. It was hard.
然后我当然情绪化了。然后检察官问，你情绪化了。为什么？我说，因为我爱他们。他说，他们是你的朋友。我说，是的。如果我当时反应快一点，我会说，可能不再是了。直到之后我才想到这一点。但那确实很情绪化。那很难。
Why? What was the hard part about it?
为什么？难的部分是什么？
Just because I do love them, and I am afraid that they are angry at me for talking. And I guess I had hoped to see a little bit of warmness or something that I didn't see from anyone other than Song.
仅仅因为我确实爱他们，而且我担心他们因为我说话而对我生气。我想我本希望能看到一点点温情，或者我在除了宋以外的任何人身上都没看到的什么东西。
When Lynette spoke, even though she was a witness for the prosecution, I have to say, a lot of what she said, it really seemed to support the defense's narrative of what happened. This was just a book club. This was just a protest. She said, quote, "They think we are an organization, I guess, called Antifa. We are not."
当琳内特发言时，尽管她是检方的证人，我不得不说，她所说的许多话，确实似乎支持了辩方关于所发生事情的说法。这只是一个读书俱乐部。这只是一场抗议。她说，引述，“我想他们认为我们是一个叫 Antifa 的组织。我们不是。”
I thought, I can't really help Song anymore, but I thought I could help the rest of them.
我想，我真的不能再帮宋了，但我认为我可以帮其余的人。
The other cooperators, all in their own ways, to varying degrees, undermined the idea that this was an Antifa plot. They testified they were surprised someone got shot. They testified the plan had been to set off fireworks.
其他合作者，都以他们自己的方式，在不同程度上，削弱了这是一个 Antifa 阴谋的想法。他们作证说，有人被枪击让他们感到意外。他们作证说，原本的计划是放烟花。
One of them testified that right after Ben Song shot the cop, Song raced past him in the dark, holding his rifle, yelling, "Oh shit, oh fuck, oh shit, oh fuck," and then he ditched the rifle and ran off, which seemed like something you might yell if you had not meant to shoot a cop. None of it seemed great for the prosecution's case. Which brings us to the last act, Act 4, The Verdict.
其中一人作证说，本·宋打中警察后，宋拿着步枪在黑暗中从他身边飞驰而过，大喊，“噢操，噢妈的，噢操，噢妈的”，然后他扔掉步枪跑了，这看起来像是如果你不是故意要打中警察可能会喊的东西。这一切看起来对检方的案子都没什么好处。这把我们带到了最后一幕，第四幕，判决。
So here we are, at the end. And the defense team that I've been hanging out with is psyched. After the cooperators testified, and the Antifa expert, who they think maybe isn't an expert, they felt very confident that the government did not prove their case. They were so confident, after the prosecution rested, the defense rested too. They didn't put on a case at all. As usual, I was hanging out with Patrick at the end of that day.
好了，到了最后。和我在一起的辩护团队很兴奋。合作者们作证后，还有那位 Antifa 专家（他们认为可能不是专家），他们非常有信心政府没能证明他们的案子。他们太有信心了，检方结案后，辩方也结案了。他们根本没进行辩护。像往常一样，那天结束时我和帕特里克在一起。
So what did you think of today, my friend?
那你觉得今天怎么样，我的朋友？
You all did it. You rested. You didn't call a single witness.
你们都做到了。你们结案了。没传唤一个证人。
Right. That is a factual statement. I was looking for something more analytical and incisive.
对。这是一个事实陈述。我在寻找一些更具分析性和深刻的东西。
I mean, it's either brilliant or it's a colossal mistake. I don't know which it is.
我的意思是，这要么是天才之举，要么是一个巨大的错误。我不知道是哪一个。
By deciding to rest, they were sending a signal to the jury about how weak the government's case was. All the defense lawyers agreed to the move. Things had gone so well for them, it seemed, there was nothing to add. And bringing their own case risked opening the defendants up to new lines of attack from the government.
通过决定结案，他们是在向陪审团发出一个关于政府案子多么薄弱的信号。所有辩护律师都同意了这一举动。事情进展得太顺利了，似乎没什么可补充的。而且进行自己的辩护有可能会让被告受到政府新的攻击。
Closing statements happened the next day. The prosecution repeats what they've been saying for weeks. At one point, they put up their own Venn diagram Antifa, the Emma Goldman book club, the Socialist Rifle Association, all overlapping at the words "direct militant action." The delivery is dry and emotionless.
结案陈词发生在第二天。检方重复了他们几周来一直说的话。在某一点上，他们展示了他们自己的文氏图 Antifa，埃玛·戈尔德曼读书俱乐部，社会主义步枪协会，所有重叠在“直接激进行动”这几个字上。陈词枯燥且毫无情感。
The defense is the opposite. They're at a high, Atticus Finch, inherit the wind level. It was exciting to watch. It was like watching the climactic scene of a movie over and over, written by different authors. "Fireworks on the Fourth of July," Brian Bouffard begins, McLain's co-counsel, "was all this was ever intended to be. Noise, lights, and a message of hope to the foreigner who resides in our land."
辩方恰恰相反。他们处于一个很高的位置，达到了《杀死一只知更鸟》那种水平。看着很刺激。这就像反复观看一部由不同作者撰写的电影高潮场景。“七月四日的烟花，”布莱恩·布法德开始说道，麦克莱恩的联合辩护律师，“这就是所有意图所在。噪音、灯光，以及对居住在我们土地上的外国人的希望信息。”
One notable moment came from Ben Song's attorney, the shooter's attorney, who made the case that Song did not intend to hit the police officer. He had fired his gun as, quote, "suppressive fire." Song, who served in the Marines, saw Lieutenant Gross jump out of the car with his gun drawn and pointed at someone running away. And so, his attorney said, he fired his gun to force the police officer to take cover. Song's attorney showed a video to the jury of bullets hitting the ground, forcing little puffs of smoke into the air. The bullet that hit the officer, he said, was a ricochet.
一个值得注意的时刻来自本·宋（枪手）的律师，他辩称宋并非意图击中警察。他开枪是为了，引述，“压制性火力”。在海军陆战队服役的宋，看到格罗斯中尉跳下车，掏枪指向奔跑的人。所以，他的律师说，他开枪是为了迫使警察寻找掩护。宋的律师向陪审团展示了一段子弹击中地面的视频，激起一阵阵小烟雾。他说，击中警察的那颗子弹是跳弹。
And then it's over. The defense attorneys are in such a good mood, a handful of them head over to the Fort Worth Club down the street, the exclusive, members-only spot. I know my way around there. It's off the record, but I can say the feeling around the club chairs is relief.
然后结束了。辩护律师心情很好，他们中的几个人去了街头的沃斯堡俱乐部，那个专属会员制的地方。我熟悉那里。这是非正式的，但我可以说俱乐部里的感觉是如释重负。
I happened to be waiting around in the courtroom hallway when the verdict came in 1 and 1/2 days later. Remember, there's no recording in there, so I don't have tape of it. I can tell you it was like an icy wind blew down the hall. The verdict is in. All the defendants' families hustled into the courtroom, and the reporters. The jurors filed in. One of the jurors was crying.
一个半天后判决结果出来时，我正好在法庭走廊里等着。记住，里面没录音，所以我没录到那个。我可以告诉你，走廊里吹过一阵冰冷的风。判决出来了。所有被告的家属和记者都涌进了法庭。陪审员进来了。其中一名陪审员在哭。
The judge read the verdicts. Eight of the nine defendants had been charged with material support for terrorists. Every single one of them was found guilty. In fact, they were found guilty of almost everything. They were charged with-- riot, using explosives-- fireworks count as explosives. And then there were the attempted murder and firearms charges that went with that.
法官宣读了判决。九名被告中的八名被指控向恐怖分子提供物质支持。他们每一个都被判定有罪。事实上，他们几乎被判定在所有指控上都有罪。他们被控——暴乱、使用爆炸物——烟花算作爆炸物。然后还有随之而来的谋杀未遂和枪支指控。
Only Ben Song, the actual shooter, was found guilty of those. Everyone was facing very long prison sentences. I run out of the courthouse into the street so I could start taping. One of the dads is out here, Ed Kent, a used car salesman from around Dallas. I talked to him a bunch during the trial. His daughter, who was 24 years old, had taken a plea deal. She testified for the prosecution. He'd come to court almost every day. A reporter asked him, what's the reaction in there?
只有本·宋，真正的枪手，被判定犯有这些罪。每个人都面临非常长的刑期。我跑出法院跑到街上开始录音。其中一位父亲在外面，埃德·肯特，达拉斯附近的一名二手车销售员。审判期间我和他聊过很多次。他 24 岁的女儿认罪了。她为检方作证。他几乎每天都来法庭。一名记者问他，里面的反应是什么？
It's horrible for the parents. Shaking and trembling and realizing their child's going to be in jail for a long time. Yeah, terrible, terrible. It's just terrible for the parents.
对父母来说太可怕了。颤抖和发抖，意识到他们的孩子要在监狱里待很长一段时间。是的，糟糕，太糟糕了。这对父母来说简直太糟糕了。
He'd already been through these emotions of realizing his daughter wasn't coming home for years.
他已经经历过这种意识到女儿几年回不了家的情绪了。
I'd be crying if I was in their situation. I've cried over my daughter's situation a number of times, by myself. But it's like, just say that it was a travesty of justice is not maybe true either, because there's-- they all were foolish.
如果我处于他们的境地，我会哭的。我为我女儿的情况哭过好几次，独自一人。但这就像，说这是一场司法误判也不完全对，因为——他们都太愚蠢了。
Fuck your daughter! Fuck your daughter!
去你妈的女儿！去你妈的女儿！
That's a friend of the defendants screaming at Kent because his daughter was a cooperating witness, or a snitch, as they saw it. I spotted Brian Bouffard, the defense attorney, headed toward his car. He was carrying a white, button-down shirt on a hanger, a shirt he'd brought for his client to wear in court.
那是被告的一位朋友对着肯特尖叫，因为他的女儿是一名合作证人，或者用他们的话说是告密者。我发现辩护律师布莱恩·布法德正走向他的车。他挂着一件白色的衬衫，那件衬衫是他带给他的客户在法庭上穿的。
That was rough.
那真够呛。
What do you-- what do you think?
你觉得呢？
I mean, I think they got it wrong. I think that they did not parse through reasonable doubt the way that the law would have them do it. I certainly don't dispute that that is their verdict, but yeah, it's just hard to take right now.
我的意思是，我认为他们搞错了。我认为他们没有按照法律要求的方式去通过排除合理怀疑来分析案件。我当然不否认那是他们的判决，但是，是的，现在很难接受。
Yeah.
是的。
He hangs up the shirt in his car. The sun is blazing down on our heads.
他把衬衫挂在车里。太阳直射在我们的头上。
God bless America, it's hot out here.
上帝保佑美国，这外面太热了。
What do you think of, everybody's guilty of terrorism? It's a material support.
你怎么看，每个人都犯了恐怖主义罪？那是物质支持。
Yeah, the material support.
是的，物质支持。
What does that mean?
那意味着什么？
Well, it means the government is going to be emboldened to continue to use the law in this way, which is a danger to everybody, as everybody ought to know. So.
好吧，这意味着政府将受到鼓舞，继续以这种方式使用法律，这对每个人都是危险的，正如每个人都应该知道的那样。所以。
And how are you?
那你呢？
Pretty rough. Not so good.
挺糟糕的。不太好。
Later, he told me it was one of the worst days of his life, losing this case. Every defense attorney is appealing this verdict. But they're kind of in a weird situation in a way I didn't fully understand until the end of the trial. The main questions of this trial, Is Antifa a terrorist organization? Are these defendants Antifa? are not actually the questions that were put in front of the jurors.
后来，他告诉我这是他一生中最糟糕的日子之一，输掉了这场官司。每位辩护律师都在对判决提出上诉。但他们在某种程度上处于一种奇怪的境地，直到审判结束我才完全理解。这场审判的主要问题是：Antifa 是恐怖组织吗？这些被告是 Antifa 吗？这些问题其实并没有摆在陪审员面前。
The jury actually had to answer a much simpler set of questions, providing material support to terrorists. It's 18 US code, Section 2339(a). It's a law that expanded dramatically after 9/11. And strictly speaking, you can be charged with it if you do something as simple as do more than $1,000 worth of damage to a federal building intending to violate the law. That's it. That's all you need.
陪审团实际上必须回答一套简单得多的问题：向恐怖分子提供物质支持。那是美国法典第 18 卷，第 2339(a) 节。那是一条在“9/11”事件后大幅扩张的法律。严格来说，如果你对联邦建筑造成超过 1,000 美元的破坏，意图违反法律，你就可以被指控。就是这样。你需要的就是这些。
The prosecution argued they did that-- the graffiti, the slashed tires in the parking lot, the broken security camera. The prosecution also argued two other things that would qualify, but the graffiti, tires, and camera damage on their own would be enough. Which is to say, the entire Antifa portion of the trial, that wasn't necessary to prove their case.
检方辩称他们做了这些——涂鸦、停车场被割破的轮胎、损坏的监控摄像头。检方还辩称另外两件事符合条件，但单是涂鸦、轮胎和摄像头损坏就足够了。也就是说，审判中 Antifa 的部分，对于证明他们的案子并不是必要的。
The judge actually pointed this out toward the end of the trial, after sitting through day after day of the government's storytelling about Antifa flags and symbols and zines and book clubs and clothing and Signal chats. The judge asked the prosecutors a question. Is it necessary to prove this stuff about Antifa? He said, whether it's Antifa or the Methodist Women's Auxiliary of Weatherford, why does it matter? It doesn't. The jury doesn't have to believe the Antifa part at all in order to convict them of material support to terrorists.
法官在审判快结束时确实指出了这一点，在坐着听了政府关于 Antifa 旗帜、符号、小册子、读书俱乐部、服装和 Signal 聊天的一天又一天故事后。法官问了检察官一个问题。证明 Antifa 这些东西有必要吗？他说，无论是 Antifa 还是 Weatherford 的卫理公会妇女协会，这有什么关系吗？没关系。陪审团根本不需要相信 Antifa 的部分，就能判定他们犯有向恐怖分子提供物质支持的罪。
So all of that was in March. Sentences in the Prairieland case came down a couple weeks ago. For everyone who was accused of material support to terrorists, six of them got 50 years. One of them got 70 years. The one defendant who wasn't accused of material support, he got 30 years. His crimes? He moved a box of zines and other stuff after the night at Prairieland and was convicted of conspiracy to conceal documents. He was not at the actual night of the fireworks. None of them had a prior criminal record.
所以这一切都发生在三月。Prairieland 案件的判决是在几周前下达的。对于所有被指控向恐怖分子提供物质支持的人，其中六人被判 50 年。一人被判 70 年。唯一没有被指控物质支持的被告，被判 30 年。他的罪名？他搬运了一箱小册子和 Prairieland 事件晚上的其他东西，被判犯有隐匿文件共谋罪。他当晚没在现场放烟花。他们都没有犯罪前科。
Ben Song, who shot the officer, got 100 years. The material support to terrorists charge can jump you to pretty large sentencing numbers. One defense attorney at sentencing pointed out that 30 years is what you give murderers or cartel members. For comparison, the highest sentence any of the January 6 rioters got, before they were all pardoned and released, was 22 years. Most of them got a lot less than that. None of them were charged with material support to terrorists or anything terrorism-related.
开枪打中警察的本·宋被判 100 年。向恐怖分子提供物质支持的指控可以让你直接跳到非常大的刑期数字。一位辩护律师在量刑时指出，30 年是给杀人犯或贩毒集团成员的刑期。作为比较，1 月 6 日国会山骚乱者获得的最高刑期（在他们全部被赦免和释放之前）是 22 年。他们大多数人获得的都比这少得多。他们中没有人被指控物质支持或任何与恐怖主义有关的事。
But the severity of these sentences, that was the judge's decision. There were two sentencing judges. At sentencing, they talked about deterrence, sending a message to anyone else with a similar ideology. One former federal prosecutor told me, the government probably sees this case as validating their Antifa narrative. It can exist in a courtroom, even if they weren't actually convicted of being Antifa.
但这些刑期的严重性，是法官的决定。有两位量刑法官。在量刑时，他们谈到了威慑，向任何有类似意识形态的人发出信号。一位联邦前检察官告诉我，政府可能认为这个案子验证了他们的 Antifa 叙事。即使他们实际上没有被判为 Antifa，这也可以在法庭上存在。
There's already another case like it in another state. The charging documents are filled with claims the defendants are part of Antifa, using some of the same language that was used in Texas. But if you look closely at this case, the Prairieland case, at what was actually in the charges, at what was said in court, at the way the plea deals were written in the end, and what the defendants were convicted of, it doesn't prove anything about Antifa at all.
在其他州已经有了类似的案件。起诉文件中充满了被告是 Antifa 一部分的说法，使用了与德州案件中相同的一些语言。但如果你仔细观察这个案子，Prairieland 案，观察指控中实际的内容，观察庭审中所说的话，观察认罪协议最终的写法，观察被告被判的罪名，它根本证明不了 Antifa 的任何东西。
Zoe Chace. By the way, Lynette Sharp, who Zoe interviewed in jail, who pled guilty as part of her plea deal, was sentenced a couple weeks ago. She got nine years. At her sentencing, she apologized to Lieutenant Thomas Gross, the police officer who was shot, and she apologized to her family. "To be human is to make mistakes," she said, "sometimes terrible ones."
佐伊·蔡斯。顺便说一句，佐伊在监狱里采访的、作为认罪协议一部分认罪的琳内特·夏普，几周前被判刑了。她被判 9 年。在判刑时，她向被枪击的警察托马斯·格罗斯中尉道歉，也向她的家人道歉。“人就是会犯错，”她说，“有时是可怕的错误。”
Well, our program was produced today by Zoe Chace and edited by David Kestenbaum. People who put together today's show include Adriene Lilly, Molly Marcello, Andrea Marks, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Ruthie Pettitto, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Laura Starecheski, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Nancy Updike, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
好吧，我们的节目今天由佐伊·蔡斯制作，大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆编辑。今天节目制作人员包括阿德里安·莉莉、莫莉·马塞洛、安德烈亚·马克斯、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森、鲁西·佩蒂托、纳迪亚·雷曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基、弗朗西斯·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、南希·厄普代克、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。我们的主编是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。
Special thanks to Toluwani Osibamowo, Kim Paschall, Thomas Brzozowski, Chris Cofer, James Luster, Marquita Clayton, Brad Sauer, Xavier de Janon, Lydia Koza, Luis, AC, the DFW support committee, Yunyong McLain, Adam Federman, Amber Lowery, Kelsey Mittaur, Jose Pagliery, Janet Reitman, David Weiss, Laci Crisler, Randi Ray, and Dylan Duke.
特别感谢托鲁瓦尼·奥西巴莫沃、金·帕歇尔、托马斯·布尔佐佐夫斯基、克里斯·科弗、詹姆斯·拉斯特、马奎塔·克莱顿、布拉德·绍尔、泽维尔·德·贾农、莉迪亚·科扎、路易斯、AC、DFW 支持委员会、云勇·麦克莱恩、亚当·费德曼、安布尔·洛里、凯尔西·米托尔、何塞·帕格利里、珍妮特·雷特曼、大卫·韦斯、拉西·克里斯勒、兰迪·雷和迪伦·杜克。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks today to This American Life partners Helen Ingram, Scott Young, and Daniel Williams. To hear our many bonus episodes and get lots of other stuff, including Lately, this weekly newsletter that I've been writing where I tell you what's happening behind the scenes of the show and I recommend a movie or a TV show-- to get that stuff, become a This American Life partner.
《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台 PRX 发送给公共广播电台。今天感谢《美国生活》的合作伙伴海伦·英格拉姆、斯科特·杨和丹尼尔·威廉姆斯。要收听我们众多的奖励剧集并获得许多其他内容，包括我一直在写的周刊通讯《Lately》，在里面我告诉你幕后发生了什么，并推荐电影或电视节目——要获得这些内容，请成为《美国生活》的合作伙伴。
The main reason we hope you do that, that you become a life partner, is just to support the show and help us keep doing it, and keep doing stories like you heard today, which I really think other people have not covered the same way. I hope you agree. You can join at thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. That link is also in the show notes.
我们希望你成为生活合作伙伴的主要原因是支持节目，帮助我们继续做下去，并继续做像你今天听到的这样的故事，我真的认为其他人没有用同样的方式报道过。希望你同意。你可以在 thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners 加入。该链接也在节目说明中。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. And from the start, he has never called our program a radio show.
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。从一开始，他就从来没叫过我们的节目是电台节目。
It was a noise demonstration, which I told them from the very beginning.
那只是噪音示范，我从一开始就告诉他们。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。